ils sont promoteurs immobiliers
dirigeants d'entreprise ou directeur
développement économique pour une
intercommunalité
près d'une centaine de professionnels
ont participé à la conférence territoire
d'opportunités paris saclay sur
l'immobilier d'entreprise
l'occasion de parler de la stratégie du
cluster faucon répondre à l'ensemble des
besoins est clairement ils sont en
évolution donc on est nous en
perpétuelle réflexion sur comment
répondre à ces nouveaux besoins à ces
nouveaux usages qu'ils répondent en fait
un nouveau profil d'entreprise la
diversité caractérise les trois
communautés d'agglomération qui
composent paris saclay notamment saint
quentin en yvelines territoire
économique de plus de 40 ans composée de
4 6 millions de mètres carrés
d'immobilier d'entreprise avec plusieurs
projets de réhabilitation pour s'adapter
aux nouveaux besoins des entreprises
c'est très important pour les
entreprises d'avoir à l'heure actuelle
que ce soit pour des petites entreprises
ou des grosses entreprises elles ont
toutes besoin de locaux modulables et
flexible c'est vraiment pour faciliter
en fait le travail en commun la
collaboration l'innovation et rendre les
choses beaucoup moins statique qu'elle
l'était avant avec des bureaux
individuels par exemple pour
l'innovation on a besoin de deux lieux
un peu hybride et oui donc maintenant
toutes les entreprises ont vraiment
besoin de ces lieux là une adaptation
qui permet à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
de rester dynamique dans ce secteur en
2018 plus de 222 1000 mètres carrés ont
fait l'objet de transactions
immobilières sur le territoire